the only real thing there is is the now
one of the points that i've been very
concerned to make
and i it's certainly in a great
tradition which reaches back to the
iching and pythagoras
is the notion of resonance that
the now is a resonance phenomenon
in which aspects of the future
and aspects of the past
clash together or interfere with each
other
in such a way as to create a kind of
standing wave
resonance of moments far in the past
potentially far in the past and
far in the future are creating
uh the phenomenon of the now this is
explains the apparently irrational
phenomenon of
fads and fashions it may be you know
that late roman times and the early 21st
century are somehow creating an
interference
pattern which is the present moment
it is rich in its anticipation of the
far
future and surprisingly
uh tenacious in its adherence to
uh themes in design
philosophy and social behavior that
really go back to
late roman times or or perhaps
dynastic egyptian times the fabric of
time
is a holographic fractal
resonating rich organic
uh self-coherent process it's a synergy
we are continually remaking the past in
the present
a perfect example of this is the term
renaissance
the renaissance was not invented until
the 1850s when a bunch of german
historians
looking back at the 15th century
discovered
the renaissance something had happened
and so it came
to be you know 350 years after its
occurrence
this is a clue to how language is really
the fabric of our reality it is
what actually happened in some kind of
ontological sense of
actually is a very small contributing
component to the history we live with
marx redefined and recreated history
robert bork would do the same thing
everybody realizes that
to advance their agenda in the present
they must remake the past and a great
deal of political shenanigans in the
20th century have
have operated on that principle i i
always think of goebbels comment
he said when i hear the word culture i
reach for my revolver this is
a perfect encapsulation of the nazi
need to remake or even to destroy
the past so that the present can be
reshaped in whatever form
the current group in power seeks to
shape it the chinese have understood
this for millennia this is why
at several points in chinese history all
the books have been
burned in order essentially to make a
clean slate
of the past so that from the present
moment
new myths new ordering principles could
be projected
back on the past and then that immense
power and efficacy that we attribute to
past
things could be utilized in the present
for
political purposes i think we need to
realize
that language arises inevitably
out of the organization of the neural
matrix of human beings
so that when whenever we create a
system of explanation whatever it is
explaining
it cannot help but be primarily
a map of our own neural organization
living beings including ourselves are
syntactical statements by the cosmos
we learned to say things that weren't
had never been said
before that concretized realities
that we now live with completely without
awareness
throughout history language has been
allowed to evolve
pretty much as an unconscious process
but i think now as we close distance
with this
flowing together of everything this
cultural global concrescence
we do not have the luxury of an
unconscious
and so in the same way that we get rid
of thermonuclear weapons and disease
bombs and these sorts of things
we also need to get rid of poisonous
linguistic processes and assumptions
which
occlude clear thinking
our politics is haunted by
a lack of clear thinking
and i'm amazed actually at
how much of our communication with each
other
is extremely low grade we really do
largely communicate with the grunts and
nods
it's very rare that people draw
themselves together
collate and make cogent their thoughts
and then lay it on to somebody else in
such a way
that the thought comes into being i
think the great political task
is to refine and accelerate the
evolution of language this has always
been
unconsciously sensed this is why writers
and poets
are intuitively felt by power groups
to become to be somehow dangerous
in out of all proportion to
their numbers or the numbers of their
followers
it's because they tamper with the most
sacred province of the state
which is the pool of linguistic
modalities that allow realities to be
concretized
the history of language has
had a tendency to emphasize certain
areas and de-emphasize others in other
words in our western languages because
there is this
subject-object dualism built into
syntax we have evolved an extremely
sophisticated language for the handling
of objects from quarks
right up to quasars but notice
how utterly impoverished our emotional
vocabulary is
anything which is amorphous
and behaves like a field rather than
being tightly clustered into a local
domain
we have very little to say about it and
yet as
uh uh intelligent organisms rising out
of a primate
substratum we are just awash in emotion
that's you know we have thousands of
emotions
per day and yet you know fear
hate uh that's about it uh affection
disgust we have maybe a dozen words
that we use for these thousands of very
very
finely gradated states of mind
and that's where uh to an even greater
degree than in the political domain
misunderstanding comes into play and
neurosis
is generated it's in the area of our
emotions
that we flounder so badly when
communicating with each other
and even when communicating uh to
ourselves within the confines of our own
mind we don't know how to say how we
feel
to ourselves or to other people
consequently there's a great deal of
stress and strain
coming out of that domain from you know
neurotic
personal relationships right up to we
can't explain to the russians how we
feel about them
they have trouble making us understand
how they feel about
the motherland and their history and
their destiny
and so forth and so on so i think the
uh place to hope for major progress
in the evolution of language is in this
domain of conveying our emotions to each
other if we could clean up that signal a
little
we would all fall into the dance
and it would look a little more like a
dance
rather than a bargain basement sale at
macy's which is
how it comes off today
[Music]
you